[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
where we dive deep into the world of
psychology and Linguistics and so on and
we explore the ways in which our minds
can influence our experiences and how
languages and language can shape
perception and the way we see the world
today we're going to talk about a
phenomenon that affects many people
regardless of their success or
achievements which is called The
Imposter syndrome
imposter syndrome is the experience of
feeling like a fraud or imposter despite
evidence of your competence or
accomplishments it's a pervasive and
often debilitating feeling that can
affect anyone from high achieving
professionals to students and artists to
YouTubers and a lot of a lot of
professions to better understand the
Imposter syndrome we're going to take a
closer look at what it is and how it can
affect us we're going to start this
podcast by mentioning and explaining a
little bit uh what the Imposter syndrome
is and why is why it's so common among
among people who they believe or pretend
to have achieved something in their
career imposter syndrome is a
psychological phenomenon where
individuals doubt their own abilities
and accomplishments and have a
persistent fear of being exposed as a
fraud or imposter it's common because it
can affect anyone regardless of their
background success or achievement no
matter how successful or how young and
old a person is the Imposter syndrome
can affect basically everyone in fact
research suggests that up to 70 percent
of the people experience imposter
syndrome at some point in their lives
and you can say that's a staggering
number so that's true and before I
research a little bit about this uh
phenomenon I I was so surprised to see
that a lot of people deal with this deal
with this syndrome and most of them
actually have no idea what this is there
are some common signs and symptoms of
the Imposter syndrome especially people
or psychologists who have studied these
symptoms can easily tell but most most
of the time normal people are not able
to see the clues or the details some
some of the common signs of imposter
syndrome include feeling like a fraud or
doubting own abilities constantly
seeking validation and reassurance from
others and also downplaying your own
achievements
showing showing only your flaws or most
of the time
hiding your achievements in front of
other people especially in front of a
large audience a large audience because
you pretend and you feel like they're
gonna judge you or you're not good
enough and uh they're going to to to
claim otherwise individuals with
imposter syndrome may also experience
anxiety and stress and self-doubt and
fear especially the fear of failure
and you may ask what are some of the
underlying factors that can contribute
to the Imposter syndrome uh we can we
can mention a few uh there are actually
several factors that can contribute to
imposter syndrome including
perfectionism social comparison uh
there's also the lack of self-confidence
and most of the time Perfection is often
set high standards for themselves and
feel like they can never live up to them
which can also contribute to the
feelings of inadequacy and self-doubt
social comparison or comparing oneself
to others can also contribute to
imposter syndrome as individuals may
feel like they don't measure up to
others who are who are better than them
or who they perceive as more successful
or more accomplished
and uh
lastly we can say that a lack of
confidence can make it difficult to
internalize one's own achievement and
accomplishments which can contribute to
feelings of being a fraud or an imposter
that's actually really interesting how
you might ask how can we overcome
imposter syndrome and how can we start
to feel more confident in our abilities
according to a psychologists there are
several strategies that can be helpful
in overcoming imposter syndrome one
strategy is to practice self-compassion
and acceptance to understand your flaws
your abilities yours your skills and to
be kind to yourself rather than beating
yourself up for perceiving failure or
shortcomings it's also important to
recognize and internalize our own
achievements and accomplishments rather
than downplaying them or attributing
them to luck or other external factors
so accepting uh the outcome of some
factors that we did something we worked
hard for for a job or we worked hard for
a project and then the the the outcome
the end result of that is our hard work
but sometimes the results are not are
not based on on uh external factors
sometimes the results are not up to our
hand and we can't control everything so
the the fact that we can accept that we
have to do our job or our part and then
we wait for the results it's also one of
the ways that we can help ourselves uh
to overcome the Imposter syndrome
another way of helping ourselves can be
seeking support from others whether it's
through therapy coaching talking having
conversations with people that you you
feel like they understand you more
friends and family or people who can
also be uh helpful in
overcoming imposter syndrome uh
based on their own experiences
especially someone who has dealt with
the Imposter syndrome can easily
understand and can empathize with you
and it's it's easy to talk to them
there's a lot of tips if you go out
there especially if you research there's
a lot of books that you can uh you can
refer to and we can we can switch gears
a little bit and talk about the Imposter
syndrome in the workplace how can you
overcome or how can you face the
difficulties of the Imposter syndrome if
you are working in a company in an
institution in a school your own
business and so on uh how can imposter
syndrome affect our careers you might
ask and what can we do to overcome it in
in the professional setting it's one of
the questions that I've asked myself in
the past few years
imposter syndrome can have a significant
impact on our careers as it can lead us
to doubt our abilities and hold
ourselves back from pursuing new
opportunities or taking on new
challenges in the workplace it can also
contribute to feelings of burnout and
stress and we can we can we can feel
like we're not doing enough we're not
good enough we're not being validated
enough we're not being valued enough and
people don't know how important my job
is or my work is and as individuals make
we may feel like we need to constantly
prove ourselves to work harder than
others to compensate for for uh are
perceived inadequacies here are some
interesting facts about the Imposter
syndrome imposter syndrome affects
people from all walks of life imposter
syndrome is not limited to any
particular profession or demographic it
can affect anyone regardless of their
age gender background education
qualification and and so on it's more
common than you think it is a lot of
Studies have shown that up to 70 percent
of people experience impulse syndrome at
some point in their lives there is a
misconception about the Imposter
syndrome and some some say that it's a
mental disorder which is not
imposter syndrome can be distressing
it's not considered a mental disorder
rather it's a common experience that
many people go through and deal with it
and also get better so uh there there's
there's a way to overcome this one of
the one of the main results or one of
the challenges of the Imposter syndrome
can be seen only when it's going to lead
us to burnout another way to understand
that we are going through uh the
Imposter syndrome
difficulties is that we can see how our
relationships change so it can affect
our relationships
uh most of the time people with the
Imposter syndrome May struggle to accept
compliments or may may push away others
which can have a negative impact on
their relationships because people don't
know how to deal with them let's say one
of the one of the colleagues at work
pays a compliment to you based on on the
work or one of the projects that you
have accomplished and then you don't
know how to how to react or you say the
wrong words at that time in that moment
when people see this as as a as a
problem and don't know what's what's uh
what's the source of the problem why
can't you accept a compliment or why do
you react in in an awkward way we can
say that it's not always a bad thing
because the Imposter syndrome can also
make us reflect and see beyond and
meditate about our own flaws it can also
be a sign that you are pushing yourself
out of your comfort zone and taking on
new challenges and it's important to
recognize a positive aspect of the
Imposter syndrome and use it as a
motivation to grow and develop further
imposter syndrome uh
touches a lot of personalities if you
have come across the uh Myers-Briggs
personality types we can we can mention
a few uh details about that as well
imposter syndrome can affect individuals
from all personality types and traits
however some personality traits may be
more prone to experiencing The Imposter
syndrome than others here are a few
examples perfectionists uh or people who
often set extremely high standards for
for themselves and may struggle with
feeling like they haven't met those
expectations another type of Personality
that uh faces difficulties with the
Imposter syndrome or overachievers
individuals who are overachievers may
experience imposter syndrome because
they feel like they're not living up to
their potential or that their
accomplishments aren't truly deserved
this can lead to a cycle of constantly
pushing themselves to achieve more
introverts as well may be more likely to
experience the Imposter syndrome because
they tend to be more introspective and
may be more likely to focus on their own
shortcomings or flaws so like they look
at the flaws and problems from within
they don't easily express or talk about
them with other people and another type
of Personality that deals with this
syndrome is that the people pleasing
personalities individuals who are
individuals who are people Pleasers May
struggle with imposter syndrome because
they worry about letting others down or
not giving or not giving enough from
their selves or not living up to their
expectations they may also feel like
they're not being true to themselves
they are lying to themselves which can
lead to feelings of self-doubt when it
comes to personalities uh one another
type that actually faces huge
difficulties with this syndrome are
highly created creative individuals
people who work in Creative Fields may
experience imposter syndrome because
they often have to put themselves and
their work out there for others to judge
so there's got to be someone who judges
your work and we can we can also mention
that most people who judge or work are
not are not prone or not expert they
don't have the right expertise to judge
or value our own work they may worry
that their work isn't good enough or
that they are not as talented as others
in their field in a particular field
it's important to know that while
certain personality traits may make
someone more susceptible to imposter
syndrome anyone can experience it
regardless of their personality type
there have been many famous people who
have openly talked about their struggle
with the Imposter syndrome
here are a few examples Maya Angelou the
late poet author and Civil Right
activist once said I have written 11
books but each time I think oh they're
going to find out now I've run a game on
everybody and they're going to find me
out
uh Tom Hanks also the oscar-winning
actor has spoken publicly about his
experience with the Imposter syndrome
saying no matter what we've done there
comes a point where you think how did I
get here
when they are going to discover that
when when are they going to discover
that I am in fact a fraud and take
everything away from me
another famous uh celebrity uh former
First Lady Michelle Obama has revealed
in her Memoir which is called becoming
you can check that out later that she
has experienced The Imposter syndrome
throughout her life saying I still have
a little bit of imposter syndrome it
never goes away that you're actually
listening to me it doesn't go away the
feeling that you shouldn't take me that
seriously Albert Einstein also claims
the famous uh physicist once wrote in a
letter quote the exaggerated esteem in
which my life work is held makes me very
ill at ease I feel compelled to think of
myself as an involuntary swindler
foreign
[Music]
this is all for today thank you for
joining in our podcast I guess I'll see
you next time with the next episode